Uh we have coconut, we have coffee, we
have banana, we have pineapple back up
over there. We have a rolinia delissiosa
here. We have casiois there and cassio
granus here which are both luminous tree
species. So they fix nitrogen out of the
soil uh into the soil through uh root
nodulation. We have another uh luggus
tree. This is an error from the puppet.
[Music]
This area here that we're in was um in
the terminal classic period a densely
populated city.
There were a lot of people here. Um and
uh so if we had 80 house mounts on this
land, average Maya household size is
about eight people. So that's 640
people. Uh so we had 640 people on this
land that left trace that we can see.
They were prosperous middle class people
that could leave something that somebody
like me would be able to recognize.
There is no way that they could have
done this with a cornbased economy.
If you step back and look at the larger
picture, it's pretty productive. Like I
said, we have about 500 species that we
use. We have marketable crops. We have
medicinal crops. We have leguminous tree
crops that fix nitrogen. We have timber
species. Uh yeah, we have a lot of food
that we eat coming off the farm. Yeah.
Um most farmers if you go into the
communities are stuck to that um
traditional farming system of slash and
burn and
doing just a two crop um cycle which is
corn and beans because that is what they
mostly consume in these communities. So
that is that has been one of the main
challenges that we have had in trying to
get them to switch from the slash and
burn into a slash and m system and also
to to switch from just planting corn and
beans to diversifying your farm. Many
people like to do slash and burn and
know at the end of the day slash and
burn is not something which is good for
the environment. Many of the farmers
also cut down trees
uh for firewood. So at the end we are
destroying the forest. How can we put
that back? Because most of our people
may not know the end effect of
it. So we have to go back and teach our
people to continue what they used to do.
The Mayans are the the oldest folks in
this part of the world and their system
of farming. You could know that apart
from setting fire they used to mix
everything and they do it. They knew
that mixing things was good for the
soul, but they never wrote it anywhere.
But yet they used to put practice
it where I'm working.
Every time I'm opening my trail cleaning
by banana, I am studying where need
help. So I just work towards that
work. I'm just a tool and I sit with it
that day happy, clean, healthy and grow
naturally. Um I don't need have I don't
water. I don't water. I don't really do
anything. I just
caretaker. Yeah. That's why most of the
time in this war here, this life here, I
have I never say I own this land here. I
can only be a caretaker. We are all
caretaker
too. And if I was an industrial farmer,
particularly a citrus farmer, I would
see leaf cutter ants as a problem. Leaf
cutter ants are actually a symptom of
other problems. They're an indicator
that your system is out of balance. Your
soil is damaged. You only see leaf
cutter ants in uh in the wake of a
catastrophe. 5,000 acres of citrus. Leaf
cutter ants are going to come in
there. Problem is the solution. So this
very good example of this. The problem
again back it up. This was citrus in
here when I bought the land. The
solution was the leaf cutter ants. Uh
and they're repairing it. They've been
repairing it for quite some time. The
solution to the problem with leaf cutter
ants is the solution to another problem
which is what do I feed my chickens? The
chickens will take this problem and
convert it to resources. They'll convert
it to meat. They'll convert it to eggs,
to feathers, and to manure. Those are
all products. And the services the
chickens are providing is pest control.
They're eating that. And then the
manureing. Those are the Maya mountain.
So this is a this is a Maya mountain.
All this is Maya Mountain. So every
hilltop is where my ancestor were
living. And farming is another thing I
believe that's a very special gift God
give us. The main thing for human being
is learn to plant your food and get to
know where the food come from and what
is
food. Cook your food, plant your food
and give thanks and praise.